mais qu'est ce que vous êtes prêt vous à
parce qu'il ya des discussions cette
semaine dans des discussions il faut que
chacun amène un petit peu quelque chose
qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts à donner
aux républicains ou parti socialiste le
parti communiste est au vert pour qu'ils
acceptent de travailler avec vous est ce
que vous êtes prêt à amender votre
programme par exemple le président de la
république a été très clair à ce sujet
la base des discussions c'est le projet
présidentiel pourquoi parce que emmanuel
macron a été réélu les 10 et 24 avril
c'était une victoire contrairement à ce
que certains auraient voulu laisser
entendre et derrière les français ont
choisi de lui donner une majorité
relative certes mais une majorité tout
de même donc le projet présidentiel
c'est la base de ces discussions et il
pourra tête c'est ce que dit emmanuel
macron enrichi ou amendé sur la base des
concertations que mènera elisabeth
bornes il ya par exemple deux grands
chantiers qu'on avait ciblé pendant la
présidentielle qui était la question
d'école et de santé sur lequel on assume
et de dire on n'arrive pas avec un
projet ficelé de a à z précisément parce
qu'on doit faire on doit travailler de
façon très concertée avec les différents
élus mais également et évidemment avec
le corps enseignant avec les médecins
pour trouver les meilleures solutions et
donc je crois que là-dessus dans
l'intérêt général on doit pouvoir
réussir à trouver des consensus mais un
autre chantier aussi c'est la réforme
des retraites parce que là vous êtes
prêt à l'amender et iard voir ce projet
pour justement qu'ils puissent avoir un
large consensus au parlement même chose
on avait également dit sur la réforme
des retraites on n'arrive pas avec un
projet qui est complètement figé on a un
objectif général une philosophie dans
cette réforme qui est d'une part d'avoir
un système qui doit être plus juste et
c'est pour ça qu'on propose une retraite
minimum à 1100 euros c'est pour ça qu'on
propose de revoir et notion de
pénibilité de carrières longues et en
même temps ce système il doit être
équilibré sur la durée et doit être
pérenne parce que moi aujourd'hui je
travaille pour payer la retraite de mes
parents j'espère que demain les enfants
pourront payer pourront travailler
pardon pour payer la mienne également et
nous qu'il ya une faute début c'était
clair
une main qu'on y avait un report de
l'âge de départ à 65 ans après il est
revenu dessus pendant la campagne ont
finalement les 65 ans c'était pas un
totem aujourd'hui quel peut être le
projet parce que la droite par exemple à
la tient à l'âge légal de départ à 65
ans edouard philippe aussi doit payer
vous allez contenter tout le monde ne
doit pas y avoir effectivement de totem
c'est tout à fait juste parce qu'il faut
garder en tête l'objectif l'objectif
c'est d'avoir cet équilibre c'est
équilibre pardon et donc ça nécessite un
décalage progressif de l'âge de départ à
la retraite maintenant tout ça doit
évidemment être discuté avec l'ensemble
des formations politiques c'est le
principe je crois du parlement tel qu'il
a été élu encore plus peut-être que sur
la mandature précédente
donc voilà vraiment dans une logique de
concertation mais gardons en tête que
les objectifs je crois est nommé sans
fixer d'âge vous garder en tête qu'il
faut décalé là je n'ai pas à un garde en
tête qu'il faut décaler l'âge de départ
précisément pour rendre le système plus
pérenne
[Musique]